[Music]
these are three objects that are kind of
mcguffins mcguffins are like uh
film objects are kind of props in the
film that you would have to uh that were
designed to actually sort of carry the
plot forward and uh all three of them
are actually objects that were in
local tv local tv shows so a kind of
three quite imaginative uh tv shows that
i remember from my i wanna say childhood
but maybe not maybe it's my teenagehood
you know yeah some years back here
[Music]
my approach to it i think of it as
something where you can also use it more
than just uh
for building the functional product but
also that it could also be used to
illustrate things to
to talk about different narratives to
expand out into other worlds
for me it's also interesting to speak to
the audience if i don't get to speak
them sometimes so you know i don't
actually get to hear what exactly is in
the obvious mind and that's normally
where you see how different the
interpretation of a world is
maybe it would spark a curiosity in what
shows these were i mean i do want it to
be open-ended in interpretation
[Music]
we often hold on to this idea of
function that it must be easily you know
measurable and sometimes in art and
design
it is uh
these are very intangible and difficult
things for example how do you calculate
how happy you are so it's hard to put a
number on these things
but the kind of understanding or what
kind of impact it can have in your life
is is far greater so it's always a
complicated thing but i think of course
that yeah that there is design in
everything yeah a lot of art is not just
um
one way um it's also it's also that
dialogue um that interaction almost the
relation relationships that are also
formed through you know seeing and
experiencing art
[Music]
you